we're going to turn now to March Madness
this is a big day fans need to lock in
their brackets before noon Eastern today
64 teams are vying for the national
championship we've been telling you all
morning long I don't really know a whole
lot about college basketball so to have
a shot at winning our office pool I set
out to find the secrets behind a winning
bracket and that led me to some experts
with tips and tricks for all the madness
well we managed to make it to mid-march
and while it's pretty chilly here in New
York City it doesn't really matter
because inside the walls of the CBS News
broadcast Center the competition is
really heating up
clearly March Madness is all anybody's
talking about
hi Stephen
but I'm not really the world's greatest
basketball fan I can't even really play
the game this is where it's gonna get
ugly
terrible at sports but I don't want to
be embarrassed in front of my co-host
Nate Gail and Tony so I'm going to talk
to CBS sports's John Rothstein he's
going to help me build the perfect
bracket the more that you know about
college basketball the worse you're
going to do in your bracket I want to
point that out explain the people who
look at a bracket and can just fill it
out with their gut are going to do much
better than the people who obviously eat
this for breakfast lunch and dinner for
the Casual fan okay what makes this
period of Time March Madness what makes
it fun the unpredictability of it and I
think you look back a year ago as a
perfect example St Peters who pulled off
arguably the biggest upset in the
history of the NCAA tournament being in
Kentucky in the first round you can
[Applause]
everybody loves to look at a bracket and
try and find who's going to be a
Cinderella team who is going to be a
sleeper who is going to be able to pull
a major upset Vlad college basketball
where the unexpected becomes the
ordinary all right so put it on the line
man what are your predictions for this
year two teams that stand out are both
from the state of Texas everybody's
talking about Houston playing in its
home City for the final four wouldn't
shock me if Baylor played in its home
state
[Music]
boss lady nobody calls me that one
that's right we call you the big cheese
okay
why are you here I know nothing about
March Madness I need a team to pick to
root for who are you rooting for I am
rooting for the University of Houston
both my parents went there
college basketball H-Town
all right so while you can root for your
hometown team or your alma mater March
Madness is really about March Madness
and for that I need a couple of
mathletes so I've got two academics from
MIT to help me out the odds of creating
a perfect bracket are one in 120 billion
but statisticians toe Zaman and Sean
Chao built a computer model that they
say is inching closer to beating the
odds picking the teams that are going to
win that are like the favorites that'll
get you an okay bracket but if you want
to win you got to pick the upsets that's
the secret sauce all right so show me
this model so now we're about to
basically run some code that helps
generate these brackets that we're
talking about yeah these are just
brackets after bracket after bracket
popping up yeah so this one has
Tennessee winning it all this one has
UConn winning it all how many scenarios
can you calculate before you actually
submit a bracket typically it's about 5
000 different scenarios 5 000 different
scenarios so can somebody do that
without using an algorithm probably not
absolutely not it would be very
difficult to do that effectively I had
to make a list of the things that I
should keep in mind when I go about
making my bracket what should I keep in
mind so typically in the first round
there's around like 10 upsets or so some
of the most common upsets are the sixth
ranked team and the 11th ranked team
where the 11th ranked team actually
beats the sixth ranked team about three
sevenths at the time which is actually
quite common but really the key is you
got to get those final eight final four
final two in the final one right to get
a lot of points
and so while I might not end up making
the perfect March Madness bracket
at least I'm gonna give it a shot
[Music]
yikes
and Sean haven't shared their algorithm
widely just yet they were kind enough to
work their magic and help build this
bracket for me I took the advice from
all the experts my producer Alyssa
candiotti and of course our boss Shauna
because I have Houston going all the way
this is my bracket folks I love it I
hope you post out the social media and
it'll be online
I know nothing let's I hope I win what
if suck if I win I think you will win
you gotta you got a computer doing it
for you so